[Music]
man you coming at me for my music but
you listen to this old stuff oh oh but
better get up out of here with all that
[ __ ] is the truth I got a boyfriend yeah
her it's okay really
we been together a whole lot of stuff we
got time my name is star two hours
daddy made me that garden Heights Mama
and Daddy says our life is here because
our people are here we got mr. Rufus
barbecue
rest early assess barbershop and daddy's
store the high school is where you go to
get junk high or pregnant we don't go
there Williamson is another world so
when I'm here I'm starvation - oh those
kids'll it basically Williamson star
doesn't give anyone a reason to call her
ghetto and I hate myself for doing it
until the weekend comes around I get
those books every time oh yeah I know
you've been ain't gonna like ease
[Music]
out of the car you know start go back
where he told you come on I'm not
playing go back today garden Heights is
reeling after the shooting of a 17 year
old black teenager by a white police
officer we live in a complicated world
it doesn't seem that complicated to you
violence it's the same story just a
different name
instead
babies asbestos you can't you [ __ ]
was threatening her
it's about more than just color it's
about black people poor people everybody
at the bottom I need to speak for him
when you ready to talk you talk I never
let nobody make you be quiet
I mean you stop I ask it is painful for
us to see so many children starving
building these houses for them just to
create a country that we always dreamed
about that day I decide that I don't
care how Pablo makes his money
only how he uses it illegal cocaine is
coming into our country at alarming
levels one kilo is worth $7,000 here in
Colombia in the United States is worth
150,000 welcome is Jeffrey they don't
fear the judges in Colombia they've
killed them I saw your interview with
mr. Escobar what can you tell me about
it
you will give him Brazilian personal
then I'll have to fire my makeup girl
I'll take you with him when he goes down
you know that don't you father Scott has
been selected
it's a disgrace this man is an insult to
every Colombian
you have money powder what more do you
want respect
you're headed straight for suicide the
story there won't be anyone left to hear
it
how do we know you are really Bob Louis
karate we prove it to you by glowing up
your station hey what do you think would
that be enough
you're marked for life help us next
change for what
now listen to me you're going to be the
future die
do you think's bar look what I was with
you know what I'm saying news for you
nobody will get in here you know they
will be afraid that I will kill them
nobody's
[Applause]
you have Dunsey reagan just say no
our music and dancing connects us on the
very first beat to the very last echo
[Music]
are you back for good here for business
they all know that gentrification is a
dirty word
in this city have you turned your back
on your family for a payout this change
isn't for us it's to remove us said
motorcade Salamis outside countdown with
my skirt
if one building stands firm it can't
complete the project they say you know
step up and he's we go inside it's
double the market price I do that we
just know if you know
you know what the hell are you doing
[Music]
how hard would you fight for everything
your father believed the New York's also
around is in two weeks this can help us
reach our goal
there's something worth preserving you
you go to your brother you need him
[Applause]
take a turn off all these lights and
tear Audis down we still all shiny
[Music]
I was doomed from the start why does one
run towards ruin why is it hold such a
fascination has been most intelligent I
congratulate you on the success of your
performance what I'm saying is that I
have lived in the grip of ice flesh
arcing of wires the Centers of the cult
is that you'll be imprisoned and kept to
hard labor for two ears it was wrong and
I have bet you'll make a classic of you
yet now they are like dear Jesus you
have luggage
we intend to effect a reconciliation
with my wife I feel sure that if I was
to see him once I would forgive him
everything rest assured I shall never
see Lord Alfred Douglas again I forbid
him did it without infernal man
okay let's run away someone no one could
find us you don't know us
then you will never see Constance again
not wearing a silk stockings today I go
too far sir well you go too far
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you figured everything my family my wife
my freedom everything
suffering is nothing when there is love
love is everything I was the love and be
like that but the price I pay for it
[Music]
who kinda do to speak to me you couldn't
lend me five pounds could you
I'm in mortal combat with this wallpaper
Oh be mine ever since ago
when I tried it I felt
so I just kept on doing it
why I don't know I thought we were
closer than most fathers and sons this
isn't us this is not who we are both of
you stop
there are moments that I look at him and
I wonder who he is
how's that boy David I'm not giving up
now
never
[Music]
you always gotta be controlling
everything doesn't make any sense right
now let us help you I don't want you to
help don't you understand that I had
such grand plans you'd graduate from
college do something amazing and now I
just want to not die who are you Nick
visited me that here this is who I am
if you could take all the words in the
language it's still in describing each
other I love you more than everything
I'm really sorry it's hard as hell to
get sober but I love my family I want to
be proud of me
[Music]
I understand how scared you are it'll
pass though it always does
Mack what you have is extraordinary
and you're gonna get it back you're
gonna find it together
God give me the strength to get through
the next three days please man
hallelujah did that today the government
announced put initiative to have
American sign something they're calling
the Patriots owes the deadline for
signing is the day after Thanksgiving
this is not America that I know
Christopher Risa we're not talking
politics I'm not gonna ruin Thanksgiving
I promise
rest assured you are duct tape no
politics you treat people who don't
agree with everything you say like the
morning sorry to be the bearer of bad
news
I came back
Wow [ __ ] hey I want it just one more
time so I'm I'm really sorry you got
tased I don't know if this because it
still electricity in my body but I am
kind
[Music]
[Music]
just these I don't want the others come
on man I slept these all the way here
people waiting you know you don't have
to be so disrespectful you've actually
carried my books here and you are Li
Israel oh we have copies of your latest
work right over there nobody is going to
pay for the right early Israel right now
my months behind in my rent and my cat
asset it's 4:00 in the afternoon
you don't run I'm hardly drunk crazy my
suggestion to you is you go out there
and you find another way to make a
living
recently found us delightful sign letter
e Fanny Brice one of my favorites I
could give you 75 oh I could give more
for better content it's a bit bland is
all yeah I can definitely get a lot more
for this one I mean the PS makes it
priceless quite by accident I find
myself in a rather criminal position
what criminal activity could possibly
involve except a crime of fashion force
I'm embellishing literary letters by
prominent writers I love his writing
particularly clever don't you think
caustic wit this was quite something
he's a wonderful I thought so too name
your price
you were looking at one month's rent
what seems to be the problem people are
on alert your name's been put on a list
a list their literary treasures one of
the kinds it's my writing you're
impersonating other people
nobody's finally Israel letters there
have been some forgeries going around to
these real looks that way good you're
stealing from me
come on my house is supposed to be
something more goodness we're probably
looking at some time behind bars what
I can't say that I regret any of my
actions in many ways this has been the
best time of my life like at the age
before guys become dicks friends if this
is located all right a lot of the time
we feel that our lives are the worst
thinking you looking anybody else's
closet you wanna trade your [ __ ] for
their [ __ ]
so let's go that's why we ride a piece
of food what that does for somebody's
spirit
[Music]
[Music]
no stealing the same
[Applause]
[Music]
Nikki what do you mean she's gone that
baby we ought to be home with your
family she's alright she's fine I've
been telling them for years you got to
figure out what you want to do with mom
when the time comes because we all know
why this thing works
I'm sorry out of here more often you got
family you got girls you got a husband
you're here plenty she was trying to go
home
she thinks she's still a little girl or
she can't figure out why she's stuck
here who's that
Oh what is there no that is he's my
boyfriend
see got any idea what I got going on
here I get to pick up mom and pops dry
clean and taking the church
grandma drink the holy water know this
you side raid and I'm not putting your
mother in a nursing home
you know everyone thinks banking loan is
so bad they don't only looking over at
the man you've been married to for the
last 20 years and thinking he must be
feeling the same way I am love is
commitment I don't have what you have
oh no that's the other honor
his name's Nick two horses me
I got my life savings dumped into this
place you're a bartender bar owner dad
[Music]
you know I'm gonna have a baby did you
know this dad
I heard we saved all your old baby
clothes
just gonna forget everything for better
or worse sickness and now that do you
part that is the promise she's my girl
you can't take my girl away from me
we'd have no pudding life Betty wife
happened to my wedding
[Music]
your son is a journalist right yes yes
very Xena we just got word he's been
kidnapped in Syria they reached out that
means my son is still alive it's illegal
to paying ransom and you won't risk
sending your people in to help what are
you gonna do that information is
classified
do you think I'm afraid of a jail
sentence
everyone who assists you you'll send
them to jail I know the government won't
help you but there is someone else I'm
here because I want to bring Indy home
we have our own Network there is only
one thing these [ __ ] respond to and
it's money you can't expect me to raise
20 million dollars we can connect you
with people to the safe return of your
son the money that we've raised is going
through a 15 of our friends who are
going to drive it to the drop-off point
[Music]
you have to deal with the consequences
of your decision
so do you scrape together enough money
to spread around some Middle Eastern
bribery Network you just decide to
swallow the awful thought that maybe you
could have done something more it's been
three months maybe I should take things
into my own hands be careful with that
[Music]
we need to buy a little more time you
need to go public and we need to do it
now the owner of the Hawks he wants to
speak to you personally
he gave us $800,000
please don't hurt my son
[Music]